Jupiter one of the most mysterious
planets in our solar system this gas
giant is massive enough to alter our
galaxy in strange and terrifying ways
it's also equipped with a massive red
spot that has the most dangerous storm
in our Solar
System Jupiter is one of our favorites
here at wh if and we love manipulating
it in tons of strange ways and today
we're going to do just that we'll go
through different scenarios where we
alter Swap and move Jupiter maybe we'll
even take some features of the planet
and bring them down to earth how could
this destroy our solar system and how
does this gas giant protect Earth well
let's start with our first scenario one
that brings us into a world where Mars
and Jupiter switch
places as
I don't know what that is is it what is
it the delicate balance of the entire
solar system exists in a gravitational
dance between planets swap the orbits of
two of them and you could end up
wreaking all kinds of
Havoc what would happen to a rocky red
planet stuck between two gas
giants how would Earth react to a
gigantic new
neighbor and why would a big shift in
gravity trigger an asteroid
apocalypse this is what if and here's
what would happen if Jupiter and Mars
switched
orbits the Sun and Jupiter are the two
largest objects in our solar system the
gravitational forces of these behemoths
influence each other's movements and
they have a big impact on the movement
of all the other planets moons and
asteroids in our Cosmic
neighborhood on the inner side of this
belt is the fourth planet from the sun
and our neighbor Mars the red planet is
located a mere 78 million kilm from
Earth that means it's eight times closer
to us than Jupiter is Jupiter is the
fifth planet from the sun located at a
distance of about
778 million km away and it's the gas
Giant's tremendous force of gravity that
could be responsible for the asteroid
belt separating the inner and outer
regions of the solar
system so if these two planets suddenly
swapped orbits would the millions of
Rocky objects in the asteroid belt come
flying right at
us let's start by checking out how Mars
would fare in this orbital
Switcheroo it would now be jammed
between the gas giants Jupiter and
Saturn this would put the red planet in
the uncomfortable position of having the
two biggest planets in the solar system
on either side of it it would be
uncomfortable because of those gas
giants gravitational pull but the pull
would be uneven and Mars would suffer a
similar fate to that of one of Jupiter's
moons IO like IO Mars would experience a
stronger attraction on the side facing
Jupiter compared to the side facing away
this would stretch and compress the
rocky planet Mars would start to heat up
from the
inside that's the reason IO is plagued
by more more active volcanic eruptions
than anywhere else in the solar system
Place Mars in a similar game of tug
of-war and the gravitational forces
could be strong enough to reactivate a
few of its own ancient
volcanoes yeah you could end up seeing
lava erupting out of Olympus Mons the
biggest volcano in the solar
system okay now hopping back over to our
side of the asteroid belt things would
be getting interesting here on Earth the
first big change you'd notice would be
the night sky being a little different
yeah Jupiter would go from appearing as
a distant bright star to being about 20%
as large as the moon looking up on a
clear night you could see its colorful
bands and spots but not everything would
be swirly and pretty in its new real
estate right next door Jupiter's
gravitational impact on Earth would be
about 64 times stronger than it is now
you know Jupiter already impacts Us From
a Distance every 405,000 years its pull
along with venuses is responsible for
droughts and intense rain with it being
this close the effect would be more
extreme and the consequences
deadly cut between the Sun and Jupiter
our planet would experience cataclysmic
problems with tidal
bulging so what you once knew as a
lovely habitable home would transition
into a volcanic
hell and that wouldn't be the Only Hell
Unleashed with Jupiter suddenly on the
opposite side of the asteroid belt all
those millions of rocks would be pulled
in New Directions toward it and that
would set more than a few on a crash
course with
Earth the objects in the asteroid belt
range in size on the massive size
there's the dwarf planet
series it's about 25% the size of our
moon and of the asteroids Vesta is an
unwieldly
530 km
across but an asteroid wouldn't even
need to be anywhere near that large to
hit Earth Earth and Trigger the
apocalypse a collision with one as small
as 1 km could be the end for
us if an asteroid about 10 km across
crashed into our planet it would result
in the sun being blocked out for a year
or more and without sunlight we'd
experience what's known as impact winter
temperatures would drop and
photosynthesis would stop this would
would lead to the mass extinction of
plant animal and human
life thanks
Jupiter now let's see what else this
crazy planet has up its sleeve remember
that giant scary Red Spot on Jupiter
what would happen if we took that storm
and Unleashed it on Earth let's check it
out Jupiter is home to some big storms
like the massive Great Red Spot which
has been swirling on the gas giant for
centuries why don't we bring it to Earth
and see what
happens how long would this Mega storm
rage how would it blow the socks off
every other storm our planet has ever
seen and why would you want to be at the
center of it
all this is what F and here's what would
happen if Jupiter's storm existed on
Earth the Great Red Spot is the largest
storm in our solar system and it's
responsible for giving Jupiter its
iconic Great Red Spot spanning 16,000 km
across this storm is nearly one and a
half times wider than Earth and it
reaches towering Heights of five 500 km
into Jupiter's
atmosphere scientists have been able to
observe this storm for 200 years now
though it's likely that the storm is
much much older than that more recently
the Great Red Spot appears to be
changing shape and
shrinking but whether it's getting
smaller or not how would this great
storm look on Earth would our entire
entire planet from surface to space be
blanketed in a storm that would rage on
forever the Great Red Spot isn't the
only storm on Jupiter but hauling over
all the gas giants storms would be a
little too devastating for our planet
you'd see massive Cyclones on both the
North and South Poles if you did and
those big bad Cyclones would be
surrounded by several smaller
Cyclones the though smaller wouldn't
mean much compared to what you might be
used to they would have wind speeds that
reach up to
350 km hour and be about 1 and 1 half
times stronger than a category 5
hurricane the Great Red Spot on its own
would be more than the earth could
really handle anyway this storm is so
tall that it would reach the
International Space Station that's more
than 400 km straight up in total this
massive storm would cover about 40% of
the Earth's surface and given what we
already know about its existence it
wouldn't appear to be going away anytime
soon scientists observed that on Jupiter
the great red spot usually hovers at the
same latitude that's because it's likely
held in place by two Cloud bands in the
planets mostly hydrogen and helium
atmosphere if this happened here on
Earth The Unlucky countries that fall
along this line of latitude would be
plagued by this Forever
Storm imagine the Great Red Spot
perpetually orbiting around the equator
if you lived somewhere like Brazil
Uganda or Indonesia you'd have to be
constantly on the Move you'd need to
stay within the eye of the storm or
else at least in there you'd be dealing
with some relative calm compared to
what's going on around it on its
outermost edges The Winds of the Great
Red Spot would reach speeds between
430 to 680
kmph even at the low end of that these
winds would be twice as fast as the
strongest hurricanes on Earth but what a
sight it would be to gaze at this storm
from a distance you'd see a power of
clouds reaching all the way up to space
wherever it hovers it would block out
sunlight potentially lowering
temperatures around the globe not much
within the storm's path would stand a
chance of
survival this goes beyond trees and your
home being Swept Away skyscrapers and
highrises are the last places you're
going to want to be it would release
unprecedented amounts of rain displace
millions of people and could result in a
NeverEnding series of devastating
mudslides and floods it would be so
powerful that several smaller but still
devastating storms could form around its
edges creating even more
chaos but could the Great Red Spot
really rage on forever and ever well
thankfully on Earth it likely wouldn't
when large hurricanes form over warm
ocean water
they pick up strength until they make
landfall at this point they lose their
primary fuel source moisture on a
gaseous Planet like Jupiter the Great
Red Spot doesn't stop because it doesn't
have any continence to collide with to
rain on its stormy parade and while you
may know this storm by its iconic red
color it wouldn't necessarily stay red
on Earth since our atmosphere most
mostly consists of nitrogen oxygen and
other Trace elements it could appear
blue or whitish to
you okay so now let's kick this up a
notch instead of just relocating the red
spot to Earth what would happen if
Jupiter's entire atmosphere transferred
over to our planet where could you be
safe from these toxic
winds how would you
breathe and how would the Great Red Spot
wreak havoc on
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if the Earth had Jupiter's
atmosphere the gas clouds churning
around Jupiter contain some of the most
toxic elements ever known so what's in
this gous cocktail well try helium and
hydrogen with a pinch of ammonia sulfur
and methane for this experiment we'll
scale the size of Jupiter's atmosphere
to fit Earth but how could we transport
it into our
air Well we'd have to go directly to the
source and siphon all those gases from
Jupiter we could send a spaceship
equipped to vacuum them up and bring
them back to Earth now that round trip
to the gas giant in back would take
about 12
years hopefully that would be enough
time to prepare our planet for this
complete atmospheric
makeover but could it end all life on
Earth adding Jupiter's atmosphere to
Earth's would put a lot more hydrogen in
our air creating a dangerous mixture
high above explosions would rock the
skyline with Force so powerful it would
shake the ground oh and did I mention
we're increasing Earth's gravity a bit
too well yeah otherwise all those gases
would Escape into space through the
farthest layer the
exosphere this boundary between space
and the atmosphere is Razor thin enjoy
this view of our mini Jupiter because
from here it only gets worse go one
layer down and you'd be in the
thermosphere here particles heated by
the magnetosphere create the glowing
aura that surrounds Jupiter so Earth
would have that now now hopefully the
thermosphere would be hot enough to
destroy meteors and other debris cuz
we'd have enough problems without
Falling Rocks beating us if you kept
going down you'd be floating in the
stratosphere this layer's winds would
tear up the North and South Poles yeah
they'd clock in as fast as 400 m/
second that's three times the speed of
Earth's strongest tornadoes but these
winds would feel like a soft Breeze
compared to the next danger inside our
atmosphere now you'd be in the
troposphere right above the Earth's
surface this layer extended to around 50
km on Jupiter but now on Earth these
corrosive clouds of ammonia ammonium
hydrosulfide and water vapor could reach
Heights of up to 20 km and on Jupiter
the surface reaches below freezing
conditions if these dense clouds blocked
out most of the Earth's sunlight
temperatures would drop
dramatically to survive we'd have to
build shelters to protect us from the
colder climate and poisonous gases maybe
we'd live underground near geothermal
vents where heat escapes from the
Earth's core because above the surface
the air will would be so deadly that a
gas mask wouldn't even save you you'd
need a space suit to withstand the gases
on the ground without proper protection
this Vortex of toxic fumes would eat
away at your eyes lungs and skin and
without enough oxygen in our atmosphere
all the plants animals and humans would
die but our Devastation would be a sight
to be behold these ammonia clouds would
create spectacular red and white bands
as they swirled around our planet the
dark red bands are called belts and
their gases would sink to the ground but
the cold air in the white bands called
zones would rise and here's the Pinnacle
of those powerful gases the storm called
the Great Red Spot we discovered this
violent hurricane on Jupiter over 400
years ago and now we've brought it to
Earth and although evidence shows that
this storm is shrinking it's still large
enough to swallow Earth
twice yeah it wouldn't leave us anytime
soon if this NeverEnding storm existed
on Earth it would funnel these gases as
fast as a category 5 hurricane it would
stretch out over
640 km covering an area one and a half
times the size of the Grand Canyon its
massive clouds would stretch beyond the
other layers of the atmosphere and into
space yeah this Tempest would destroy
cities around the equator anyone not
living underground would live in
constant Danger from Ecuador to Congo
and all the way to
Indonesia over 700 million people would
be displaced or wiped out Earth's
imported atmosphere would look great
from above but life on Earth might be
all but extinct if we brought the Great
Red Spot
here okay so what if instead of the
atmosphere we took Jupiter's magnetic
field well keep watching because that's
a story for another what
if
[Music]